foreign
[Music]
thank you
NBA bets you love
finally we have reached the NBA Finals
fellas how are we doing how are our beds
going let's start off with you Ryan I
know you uh
you might be feeling a little down right
now though Celtics are not in the finals
but uh are we are we are we are are we
happy that the NBA Finals is here we
didn't want to start off with better
Vibes than that you could have been like
it why and your hair is looking nice
today or like Ryan how are you enjoying
the good weather in New York it's I mean
we doing this
yeah you know the last time we did the
show you guys were telling me I was
showing up to my own funeral we took it
to seven
I did take it to seven I did take it to
seven I'm not proud of it I was just
right that's a good question would you
would you have rather it just been a
sweep or would you you know just quickly
like would you have rather been asleep
no no I wouldn't have I would have
rather win the series but yeah
yeah exactly yeah
welcome everybody to the show man and
welcome everybody to the show my name is
Greg Ivory to your left man we like to
call producer Ryan to your right it's a
man I like to call MB y'all might call
him Michael Bolin but he is the man of
the app uh all right guys we're gonna
build this parlay everybody know we we
build some parlays here on the show
we're gonna build this one but we're
only going to be on this one for about
10 minutes because we got some other
stuff we want to get to so drop your
Best Bets tonight for the NBA Finals
game one drop those in the chat we're
trying to get to like around a 10 to 1
parlay Ryan so like 10 on One
not a hundred to one not 50 not 20
around 10 okay here we go we're going to
get around ten to one we're talking heat
nuggets
Ryan what they talking about in the chat
man yeah they're asking me how I enjoyed
the Celtics downfall from let me call
the specific person out fuego fuego
blood shout out to you your plays will
not be read by me today
don't worry Fuego blunt oh yeah I'll
read over it yeah I'll read it
that's awesome
um JJ Kidd what about Kayla Martin four
plus threes
that's okay this is so funny because
this that was like unintentionally right
back at Ryan yeah I feel like the chat
just knows that Ryan is down tremendous
and they're just going after him tonight
I'm on Caleb Martin's under I can't I
don't know if I could do Kayla Martin
four plus threes
I'm seeing something about Eric Gordon
yeah I like I like the uh I like the
Aaron Gordon play I'm trying to figure
out if he means
plus 11 and a half over and eleven and a
half points maybe I'm not sure I just
know that Aaron Gordon might end up
getting guarded by Caleb Martin a lot
this series if they play him at the four
he's had a quiet postseason but I think
maybe his standards he probably had his
best NBA season of his career this year
he could be like a sneaky player this
this uh this series if the Nuggets
really go off like
I could see him having a really good
series
I like it I'm in the
go ahead I mean yeah it's cool
I'm I mean if you talk about it Ryan if
you like it go ahead talk about it move
on but go ahead no no I was just gonna
say it I mean like it's not too far off
so if we wanted to do 10 plus minus 330
I don't think it's gonna necessarily
kill our Vibe here so
um if we wanted to start out that way
and then we can kind of go for something
a little bit juicier I saw Aiden uh 1410
said Miami Heat plus 34 and a half that
could be yes we go next
yeah that sounds great it's only going
to be
minus 35
000. yeah
I'm definitely into that I'm seeing a
lot of Jamal Murray uh ABS still Jamal
Murray Legacy game
um I I I saw Asher
chassan Jamal Murray three plus threes
do we think he's gonna have a a similar
series
that he had against the Lakers he was
balling in that Lakers series uh I think
it might be a little bit more
challenging because of the Guard play
for Miami and they like to defend but uh
do you guys think he can go get three
and a half threes tonight
I don't know that's a that's a number
that's like pretty tough to to handicap
right like we can't we won't really know
if he's gonna go off until we find out
you know in the second quarter if he's
already got 30 points he does get the
volume though I think he's shot like
between 10 and 12 in most of the
postseason games and I gotta think the
heat are gonna play a little bit of Zone
if he's off the ball I could see him
knocking a few of these down maybe four
is too many but three could get us a
good number I don't know what do you
think Ryan
I think let's see what three does get us
I like Jamal Murray in this series a lot
I mean minus 220 you pair that up that's
not going to get it done for us just
based on where we need to go
um so I think we probably have to make a
decision there but
I I mean I like it I mean who else is
really gonna like do all the scoring for
for I mean like we have Aaron Gordon to
score 10 plus
I don't know I don't know I like I I
fear a little bit uh like if we lean too
heavy on Denver and then that game the
game script goes the complete opposite
way and we're cooked you know well I see
another play in here though
Omega
Omega saying Joker 14 boards you're
welcome
that's definitely not his line we're
gonna need some plus money playing
business line and
uh 14. oh my God yeah yeah what does
that even do for us nothing we might
have to get the Aaron Gordon plan MP mpj
points to ABS still is in the comments
saying if we don't want to touch Jamal
Murray
uh Michael Porter Jr
point total I'm I actually love the I
love the porter Junior play he's gonna
get as many three-point looks as he
wants especially if the Heat plays on
I think I've bet him to score 15 points
in a lot of these games this postseason
I wonder what his number's at it's
probably 15 and a half but that should
be a good spot too I don't know if I can
depend on yoke it's 13 and a half
rebounds that's just like that
astronomical number for even money
that that is a lot uh I wanted to give a
shout out to my guy KJ Mullins uh who
him and I went to war these past a few
shows with his Miami Heat he asked me
how this was doing in Cancun
so
okay
listen bro the chat is bringing receipts
now yeah the chat knows listen they're
giving me my own medicine I you know
respect respect
um yeah let's take a look at mpj I think
he's gonna make at least three threes
what is his number at it's probably bro
if you think he's making three his
number's at one and a half oh nope nope
two and a half that's on me well we're
gonna have a situation there what's his
point total at
yeah that's a good call because
that's minus 160 what's this point total
that's right point total is 15 and a
half
so what if we did what if we went out on
a limb and did Michael Porter Jr to
score 20. oh
ho ho ho
instead of the two and a half
it's a man the two and a half threes is
minus 160. that's like not gonna get us
anything I just don't know because we
already did took his over if this is
gonna do for us what we want it to oh
okay take take the take the threes out
wait what if we what if we kept the
threes in and took out the rebounds yeah
definitely yeah I don't know I'm scared
that makes sense that makes sense
we could also so we're assuming we're
assuming that mpj is gonna have a huge
game one he makes three threes
and maybe more but we're not gonna go up
to five because that's crazy and then
gets us a dub I don't hate it
yeah dabble with some jokic assists
why are you think an eight plus
uh
uh I was thinking more like over ten and
a half
11 plus man's a walk and triple double
man's a walking triple double listen
I've been cooked by this guy's assist
line like way too many times yeah I was
just getting ready to say that yeah
what if what if we just do 10 even I
mean yeah instead of the hook
that works we just needs
ah okay I don't want to be the guy we
need we need something Miami Heat in
here because
definitely way too heavy on the Nuggets
definitely all right
um I'm seeing under Jimmy 28 points by
scrap6 I don't know if I agree with that
one but uh
I also
also see
Martin over 15 and a half points Ryan I
know you won't like that one that's why
I read it yeah it's literally because
thank you you know I just just knew it
would rub you the right way not the
wrong way but the right way uh you
weren't in three threes Martin three
threes
that doesn't plan to that doesn't play
into Ryan's narrative no yeah does it
fit my agenda that's gonna be a no
I guess how Lowry over 20 points I don't
know if we're gonna rock with that but
bro's reaching 20 points the legend
three two seven six
yeah that's kind of crazy Kyle Lowry
Legacy game
I I will say just in terms of where
we're at right now
if we like the threes
do we need the 20 points I feel like we
should eliminate one of those two plays
I know we don't have a ton of time but
yeah we got two more borders two more
two more minutes guys and then we go
let's take out the points
and then let's go to some heat props and
let's get let's get wild with it man
[__] it yeah can I say that word I don't
know if I can say that word I'm sorry
Max my bad
I forgot where I was for a second
that won't happen again sorry Mom
uh do we want to do
man is this true's gonna get lost
tonight I think he is I think he is so
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna just tell you
right now in seven of the last 10 games
he's scored over his nine and a half
point total what's his point total
tonight oh it's minus 104.
I mean these cash this for us before and
he's probably gonna hit three threes
so I don't hate that at 10.
do we want to go as far as say 11 and a
half I'm with that yeah four points yeah
all right now we're in business here now
we just need one more and it doesn't
even need okay okay
I see Gabe over on threes I see Lowry
overboards
somebody dropped in here Jimmy six
assists
numbers at six and a half I see jokic
under one and a half threes
Jimmy six assists little stoop little
stool Jimmy six assists
let's see what that does can we can we
get to six even uh where where his line
is at six so
we just need one more though to get over
yeah yeah I'm I'm if we wanted to do
this you want four
you want four wanna go four Ryan uh uh
we can see if that were
you know oh it does not work no all
right it's so close what if we go four
and a half over four and a half so five
that'll do it that's ten shooter look at
shooter over here look at that let's go
that's ten stop trying me come on
okay the only thing I will say is
is there a world where we like this we
like Jimmy's assist so much that we do
six assists and eight assists for jokish
instead of Genesis uh I can be told no
I'm not I don't have too much pride no
I'ma tell you no because we have to move
on fellas we we gotta move on we gotta
move on we're locking it in we're
locking it we're locking it in we're not
second guessing and we're locking this
one in uh Ryan can you review for the
people one more time yes sir Aaron
Gordon
10 plus points Michael Porter Jr over
two and a half three pointers made
Nikolai jokic 10 plus assists uh Max
strus is Gonna Get Loose for over 11 and
a half points and Jimmy Butler over four
and a half assists that's five legs plus
10 27.
yeah we've never said that before by the
way we've never said that before that's
the first time saying we feel good yeah
no never liked them never ever said that
one before if if you want to tell our
parlays make sure you head on over to
FanDuel Ryan tell the people
what's up yes sir yeah if you you know
head over to FanDuel it's your first
time and you want to you know sprinkle
some bets bet five dollars and get 150
in bonus bets guaranteed now what you do
with those bonus bets I don't
particularly care you could do whatever
you'd like with it but you spend five
dollars and you get that in bonus bets
so go for it
go get those if you didn't know you can
use a no sweat bet on this same game
parlay tonight so this is actually just
free we're just putting it in and it's
gonna hit and you're gonna get your 1027
on a 10 BET 127 or 100 and 27 cents or
whatever it is
but if it doesn't hit you get the money
back anyway so yeah let's go it's you
know there it is that's a great call
that's a great couple this is risk here
it is risk free win-win you know what I
mean
you guys don't know what I mean thank
you I mean Ryan that was delayed that
was delayed but it's the connection it's
the connection yeah yeah okay okay I got
you I got you got you are across the
country uh here we go hey NBA Finals is
here fellas NBA Finals is here we're
talking Best Bets
for the series
and tonight so we're talking best best
for the series and tonight uh we're
gonna start off with my man Michael
Bolin we're going to start off with you
Michael Bolin we're talking tonight's
game and the series
give us the place please brother
all right so first play for the series
I'm rocking with my former Chicago Bull
Jimmy Butler
25 points in every game of the NBA
Finals let me just quickly walk you
through this he has hit 25 at least in
14 of the 18 playoff games this year
man's been on a tear he is the focus of
that Miami Heat team I think he gets
there he's probably going to get a bunch
of them at the line but the thing to
remember here if you like the Nuggets
this should be a pretty short Series so
that means he's just got to score 25 in
five games maybe you know so at plus 650
seems like good value for Jimmy and
tonight specifically
I love kcp to score over his 10 and a
half points I believe it's minus 106 on
FanDuel
this guy's gonna have as many wide open
threes as he wants especially if the
Heat play a Zone he's going to be wide
open in the corner on the wing he does
get to the hoop also so he could get
some of these at the line I'm expecting
a big series from kcp and mpj so go lock
those two in I know they're on both
they're on different sides but you know
the money don't matter can't take you
can't you can't think about it too much
just bet the stuff that comes to you so
those are my two plays
there it is my boy MBA y'all better pay
attention y'all better pay attention
because if we was probably ranking uh
the BR betting staff and who's hot right
now and who would be number one and B
would definitely be in consideration uh
it would be in consideration of being at
the top now Ryan I don't know if I can
say that for you yeah I don't know if I
can say that for you how did we get here
but you know we I beat you to the punch
because I heard what you were gonna say
I beat you to the punch that so I don't
I can't say that for you but with that
being said you do have a Best Bet and
you also have a bet for tonight
yeah no I saw I listened dude I saw the
rankings that you put up let's let's not
pretend like you're not in control of
the rankings here okay put me in
honorable mention it's a little gross a
little disgusting uh disrespectful maybe
uh but yeah we move it's okay so all
right for my best bet for this series
um if you know me you know I like juice
all kinds of juice and Nikolai jokic to
score 50 plus points in NBA in any NBA
Finals game I mean oh my God oh my God
do you not think that Nikolai jokic is
going to have a legacy series first of
all it's a good bet yeah the the nuggets
are gonna make this nice and quick and
painless oh well not if you're a Heat
fan it'll be painful but painless for
the rest of us but listen
it's a little Troublesome that this is
you know we're only gonna get four games
to cash this but
jokic versus bam might be the biggest
mismatch I've ever seen
um bam is just not that guy he's not
that guy pal and Nikolai jokic is and
that's just it's as simple as this like
the last I think the last time we saw
this was Giannis in game six uh two
years ago in the NBA finals
the jokic is like if you can't see the
storyline of jokic getting
Finals MVP the year he didn't get the
regular season of VP and everyone this
is the MVP that matters uh then I don't
know what to tell you maybe you're not a
ball Watcher I'm not entirely sure but
this is my best bet for the series I
love it plus 2300 I've already dabbled
in it uh I can't wait to win a lot of
money off of it I think that this is
might be mispriced who knows uh best bet
for tonight what's up what's going on
what's up no hold on I mean I didn't
want to I didn't want to stop your mojo
I didn't want to be that guy no no you
you slid in there at the right time go
ahead
I just want you to know bam is a
four-time all-defensive player you know
that right
I I I I yeah I know that you know that
Nikolai jokic is a two-time back-to-back
MVP
you know that I I do know that okay
resumes
correctly for resume but that's all good
but okay all right okay I just wanted
you to know the guy you were talking
about Essen Brad that was going to be
guard it's a four-time all defensive NBA
all NBA you know four times I and I I
will I'll let you know this man it's not
that easy to get a job right you don't
just submit a resume and then somebody
says you got the job you got to show up
to the interview so they could do the
eye test right bab's resume will get him
the interview the interview the I tested
don't pass he ain't getting the job
simple I like that I love that Ryan I
love that so go ahead go ahead to
tonight's Pick best bet for tonight uh
Caleb Martin under 16 and a half points
listen I gave it out at 16 and a half uh
very unfortunate that I am a sharp and
this line has dropped to 15 and a half
so if you're hearing this now you're
like oh man I wish I knew yeah well
unfortunate right the line dropped uh is
that 15 and a half now still love it uh
he's he is not a star I like the graphic
that we have up there he's not a star
um He's listed under star player props I
mean what are we doing what look at this
you got a star player props you scroll
all the way down who is this dude you
know what I mean and three weeks ago I
asked you who's came love Martin you
guys would say who
who the guy on the guy in the Hornets
like no that's Cody his twin brother uh
I don't know this guy nobody knew this
guy until the Celtics series people are
getting all hot and bothered about the
post we made on social I called him a
bum on the bench that's what he was
that's what he was you know like me and
being honest listen I've been called so
much worse on the internet and people
are like oh my God how could you call
him a bum that's harsh BR betting this
guy's a fool maybe I am a fool but I'll
be a rich fool after tonight so who
cares
there we go that's it I got that right
it's fired up I love that right I hated
that dude my entire ride into this
office it was like a bum a bum on the
bench how could you it's like who are
you Caleb Martin's like brother Mother
what's going on what are we getting so
angry about
Ryan
a lot of people a lot of people have
been called bums before Caleb Caleb
Martin's not above
Caleb Martin's not a bum though he's not
uh
you sound like the comments I've I've
been watching him since College since
the Nevada days
and uh he's not a bum he's a bucket he's
a bucket as we've been seeing uh but I
guess it's my turn
Kayla Martin is he made himself a lot of
money in the last two weeks that's what
I know yeah
yes he did go ahead Greg bring us home
baby let's go he he definitely did make
a lot of himself a lot of money in the
last a couple weeks but uh I'm gonna do
it backwards I'm gonna start off with my
game play and then I'm gonna go to the
to the series play uh so for the game uh
my man
kcp
adavius catavius Caldwell Pope
uh I'm gonna go that I'm gonna say that
he's gonna go over one and a half three
pointers I think I think that he's gonna
have to be a part of the Nuggets offense
in order for them to win this game I I
personally think that the Miami Heat
they're gonna try to limit the other
guys jokic you you mentioned Ryan yokich
he's gonna do what he do he's gonna be
himself but I think in order for the
Miami Heat to win they're gonna try to
have to limit the other guy so I think
the focus is going to be on Jamal Murray
and that's going to make my guy kcp have
some open shots and I think he can go
knock down too I think he can go knock
down too
that's it for
can I support your take
the last five games against the Heat two
four two five and two
that sounds like a lock to me
yep there it is I mean he's knocking
them down and I only need him to go
knock down two
let's go that's it now
series play the series play the series
play
this team I'm Gonna Keep it I'm gonna
keep it short and sweet I ain't doing no
player performance doubles no nothing
I'm going who's going to win the NBA
championship and I am rocking with the
Miami Heat Ryan you mentioned I test I
saw this team
come back from almost being an
elimination in the bubble
they beat the Bucks
they beat the Knicks and they also took
out your Celtics they passed the eye
test
now it's time to go show everybody to go
show everybody in the world who they
really are Eric Spoelstra great coach I
think he's going to be a Hall of Fame
coach Jim easy buckets Jimmy buckets
hand me I heard he's trademarking hammy
buckets because he is him
my man bam out of Bio Ryan you
disrespected him earlier I did it's a
two-time All-Star four-time all-team
defensive NBA player bam out of Bio he's
trying to make a name for himself
I can go on and on about this Miami Heat
team undrafted undrafted free agents
they have the story they are The
Underdogs and I'm rocking with them I'm
rocking with The Underdogs I think they
can go get one in Denver get one out of
the two in Denver and that's going to
change the series let's rock with the
heat man I'm rocking with the heat
I respect it Greg a lot of a lot of
things have been said about this uh
about the Heat this post season almost
lost to the Bulls in the play-in three
percent chance to win against the
Celtics almost Blue lead and showed up
on the road to win you're right they did
pass the eye test
but I can't agree but I can't agree
honestly if the Heat win
I won't be shocked because they've done
so well this whole postseason
but the nuggets have been playing Elite
basketball since the beginning of this
whole thing so maybe maybe if maybe if I
had it beforehand the value would have
been a little bit better
but I don't hate your play I'm just
saying I think the nuggets are really
going to take this thing
we'll see we'll
we'll see
Miami Heat
Sealy 15 is saying woof woof you like it
there it is
barking in the chat all right uh Ryan
let's see what else FanDuel has to ask
for us
let's ask the audience you guys give us
a playoff props give us playoff props
that you guys like get in the chat tell
us what's up uh is there anything that
you guys liked
my man Mellie dropped one on us earlier
uh on BR betting that was crazy it was
it was crazy uh
it was any any Ryan's player to score 60
in a Finals game listen man I don't
think this is listen it's not it's not
gonna happen but it's not crazy to take
this for ten dollars at plus 9 500. like
what if someone goes berserk Jamal
Murray has scored 50 uh in a playoff
game before that epic game in the bubble
against Donovan Mitchell you know
Mitchell wait right you know you know
Murray can go get him if he gets hot he
had 30 points and a half against the
Lakers
I think your best bet here is jokic and
if he is really who we think you know is
going to dominate bam according to Ryan
which I tend to agree with I think there
is a little bit of a mismatch there
Ryan I feel like if you're going to take
them to score 50 you might as well
sprinkle this oh five bucks get you 400.
I already did I woke up and I saw the
post from Mellie and I was like this guy
read my I I placed it last night and I
woke up and I saw it and I was like he
knows ball he knows what he's doing
I see uh bagel and lock saying Bam's
getting nine boards if he does not I'm
in serious trouble
um Bagel advice
the locks haven't been made of metal
recently not to you know not to get on
our guy but
you know fin sanity is saying Caleb
Martin two plus threes in every Finals
game at Plus 460.
I know your opinion Ryan I want to know
what Greg thinks here
like that play I told you guys about
Caleb Martin he's gonna he's one of the
scorers on that Miami Heat team right
now he's one of their guys and I think
that he's gonna go shoot threes he hit
all seven I I don't know how many he's
hit in a row but he had all seven in the
last series easily
if the numbers back it up it doesn't
mean you know it might be a little
different coverage whatever but that man
he was a walking bucket in that Eastern
Conference Finals I know why you mad
Ryan
he's not a bum he's a bucket now I
listen I'm just I I'm reading all the
chats from the people who put 305 in
their username these people don't know
that we're gonna be with them four times
throughout this final so I'm their worst
nightmare we'll be here for game five
when the nuggets are up 3-1 I'll be
dancing on their grave you know all of a
sudden we got Kayla Martin's family here
in the chat so I you think you could
keep receipts chat I got the receipts
baby I got them dude I got screenshots I
wrote the usernames down get check your
Bleacher Report DMS your boy's gonna be
there
I ain't going nowhere we need to make a
meme of just like Ryan creeping around
in people's DMS with receipts
City of Miami gets heated when people
say their team may not be that good
listen you're in the finals your team is
very good I have respect for your team I
am a Celtics fan you're in the NBA
finals this is an awesome run it's not
disrespectful to say that the nuggets
are the best team in the NBA and it'll
probably end here
you know it's a great run it's one of
the best runs we've seen in the NBA
since like 1999.
I'm not gonna lie to you Ryan
I'm gonna be in big trouble if the
Nuggets don't win this thing so I agree
with you I need the Nuggets to win this
series so bad I know a lot of people
that I'm very close with including
people on this team who need the Nuggets
to win this series so
I'm with you man I'm fine with the story
I'm down with the underdog narrative I
love Jimmy Butler but yeah it's great
let's get it done nuggets get it done
Denver
Hemi Butler well you guys remember that
Hemi Butler at the end of this series we
are going to be talking about him
and y'all know who I'm talking about
Jimmy Butler uh do you guys like any
other any other props that that
draws you guys attention did you guys
see anything in the in the comments I
see Chico 97 says Kyle Lowry over three
and a half assists uh
uh anything more juicy
uh the more that I read the chat the
more I like the nuggets at minus 460.
that's just for us
that's what I'll say ma'am let's go get
this money bro yeah
put a quarter in Ryan and he's not gonna
stop no I'm not dude this
this me must have not been aware of what
I did to this to the city of Sacramento
don't don't start this with me man don't
start this
you were a fan of Sacramento what do you
talk like yeah and I ended there some
are saying it was the reverse jigs
I don't forget yeah I don't forget okay
okay brother
you ended their season you ended the
king season I did it it was all me
that's on me
let's get on the party here let's get on
the butt here hey hopefully you guys uh
is is is is trailing our our parlay
um Brian do you want to tell them our
parlay one more time before we get up
out of here
let's do it why not uh Eric Gordon ten
plus points Michael Porter Jr over two
and a half uh made threes Nikolai jokic
10 plus assists Max struce over 11 and a
half points and Jimmy Butler over four
and a half assists five legs
plus 10 27.
there it is there it is there it is man
hey let's get on the body here some
money to be made we gotta go watch these
finals my name is Greg Arby to the left
of your screen is the man we like to
call producer Ryan
let's all take a moment of silence for
the Boston Celtics
and then so you're all right the man I
like the
fan of the app uh we're up out of here
man it's time to go win some money peace
Ryan you're the only one to not make you
you weren't silent
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]